welcome back to curious archive
this video is the finale of my two-part
series on the biology of darwin iv an
alien planet explored in the book
expedition by wayne barlow which i have
a link to in the description
on this perilous world deadly predators
strange herbivores and uncategorizable
oddities are still waiting to be
discovered so follow along on this
first-hand account of an expedition
across a spectacular planet a journey
that will end with an encounter with a
mysterious observer
i am now one week into my survey of
darwin iv to the east of the amoebic sea
i encounter the monolithic skull of an
emperor sea strider that appears to have
died long ago i notice a herd of
short-legged herbivores called literal
lopes taking cover at the skull's base
i soon realize what they're hiding from
a shadow swoops overhead
the literal lopes scatter in all
directions in the resulting panic a lone
literal lope is knocked to the ground
with a heavy thud and the shadow swoops
in from above
this aerial predator is called a skewer
and it is the uncontested ruler of the
skies of darwin 4 with a wingspan of
almost 50 feet or 15 meters at a glance
the monstrous skewers almost resemble
biological stealth aircrafts while the
idea of an animal converging on a jet
like shape might seem surprising the
real anatomy of certain birds of prey
and stealth aircrafts are quite similar
due to the universal constraints of
aerodynamics the skewers take this
convergence to a new level however
through their ability to internally
create methane gas which is then
combusted within the four jet pods
located on their wings for propulsion
and when a skewer chooses a target the
hunt is already over i watch as a skewer
rises into the air and pitches downward
with its stinger pointed forwards in an
instant it impales its prey i count
myself lucky i'm too small to be its
target yet as i watch the skewer fly off
i get the strange feeling i'm not alone
even as i continue on i feel like
something is watching me
putting these feelings aside for now
further east i reach a sprawling
flatland where the margins of the
amoebic sea have receded within this
region which was once the sea floor i
spot a sackback a bulky red lifeform
with peculiar anatomy this species gets
their name from a sac used to store
pre-digested food from the amoebic sea
almost like the world's weirdest camel's
hump even stranger however is that this
sackback's stored food isn't for itself
but for its mate under the sand a second
sackback has buried itself up to its
head along with its eggs and relies on
the above ground partner to bring it
food strange as this might sound earth
hornbills exhibit a highly convergent
behavior when a hornbill needs to
incubate its eggs it completely seals
itself within its nest while its mate
dutifully brings it regurgitated food
for a period lasting up to four months
it's a risky endeavor which requires a
tremendous amount of trust between the
two parents so it is strangely moving
that such a social behavior would arise
not just on earth but on a planet as
perilous as darwin 4.
journeying to the south i find myself
face to face with a rather unsightly
creature this is a bladderhorn an animal
that is so bizarre it is at first
difficult to categorize it lives at the
base of an equatorial mountain range and
thankfully seems to feed on plants
rather than other life-forms with their
mid-sized grazing niche and bellowing
calls these creatures are in many ways
the elk of darwin 4.
another bladder horn approaches from
behind the first one isn't happy with
this invader and bellows while it
inflates its glowing horns when this
fails the two butt heads
like birds of paradise these bladder
horns appear to engage in bizarre
displays over territory and mating
rights indeed many birds of paradise
rituals are just as strange as the alien
bladderhorns which is saying something i
decide to leave the bladderhorns to it
and see what other lifeforms dwell in
this mountain range scaling the
foothills of the equatorial mountains i
find myself caught in a heavy rainfall
taking shelter under an overhanging rock
i realized two leathery brown creatures
are huddled nearby also hiding from the
storm these are keeled sliders peaceful
mountainous herbivores which thankfully
aren't aggravated by my presence like
mountain goats keeled sliders can
maneuver down steep slopes with
remarkable ease using their specialized
front limbs yet these keeled sliders are
staying remarkably still a scan detects
20 small life forms in the tiny cave
behind the pair it seems these are young
parents guarding a nest of newborns i
don't want to disrupt them and since the
rain is letting up i'll be on my way
after a grueling climb i reached the
summit of the equatorial mountains
looking to the horizon as i catch my
breath i spot a herd of four-legged
grazers on the peaks beside me these are
spring wings and while they look
ordinary from a distance spring wings
are the champions of the chilly alpine
skies a gust of wind howls overhead i
look up and see an adult spring wing
leaping into the air above me unfurling
gliding appendages that allow it to soar
out into the abyss watching a cow-sized
organism take flight is a majestic and
bizarre sight made possible thanks to
darwin 4's thick atmosphere and low
gravity their fixed wing structure
resembles the body plan of draco lizards
which can glide in a similar manner
although they're much smaller just as
i'm about to depart i notice something
moving on the rock above me but it
quickly recedes from view it seems i am
still being observed heading northwards
i'm drawn to a commotion caused by a
stampeding herd these behemoths are
called uns creatures named for the sound
they make when they exhale through their
dorsal vents heavyset herbivores ants
are the lumbering bison of darwin 4 who
rely on their herd to stay safe while
they browse for plants yet unth herds
aren't without conflict before my eyes
two ants engage in an earth-shaking
battle for dominance throwing their full
weight into each other their posturing
reminds me of muskox clashes on earth
yet despite the occasional clash the
unthird seems to be remarkably
tight-knit as they are united against a
common enemy the weather
this far to the north nothing is more
dangerous than the dropping temperatures
i've now reached a wind-swept region
where the ground is covered in
near-permanent ice and most life forms
on darwin 4 can't survive for long yet
even in this extreme biome some
creatures have found a way to adapt to
the cold
close by i notice an organism which at
first glance appears to be in distress
as it's half buried in the snow at an
awkward angle looking closer however i
realize that this creature called a
tundra plow is actually scouring under
the surface for food plenty of earth
animals forage for food under the ground
and many others tunnel under the snow
for similar reasons but the tundra plow
makes such behaviors look extremely tame
by comparison staying halfway
underground in a manner that looks like
a face plant for long periods it's a
somewhat absurd method of survival but
it appears to be working reasonably well
trekking as far north as i can safely
travel i've reached a glacier cap where
only the most extreme species can live
here i find the shivering ice crawlers
small nondescript organisms that slowly
make their way across the glacier's
surface feeding on microorganisms with a
mouth on the underside of their shell
with their segmented bodies the ice
crawlers have converged on a body plan
similar to giant isopods crustaceans
that can also endure frigid temperatures
i'm about to turn back when perhaps the
strangest life form i've seen dashes
across my field of vision this is a rime
runner a fast-moving creature that hops
over the ice on its single foot while a
single legged animal is highly unusual
it's not altogether unheard of in the
natural world as most bivalve mollusks
like clams also possess only a single
foot which they use as a bizarre form of
motion it's likely that the rime runner
evolved from a similar organism even
stranger than this creature's foot
however is the parachute shaped
structure on the front of its head at
first i thought this orange structure
was a separate life form but it's
actually connected to the rhyme runner
via a thin neural cable looking closely
at the floating organ it seems it's a
sensory packet that helps the rime
runner better navigate through
echolocation almost like an organic
radar dish a unique life form indeed
returning to the warmth of the southern
reaches i worry i won't find creatures
as strange as the rime runner my worries
quickly fade however when i spot two
crescent-shaped lifeforms hovering in
the distance
these wrinkled oddities are rugo's
floaters rather lazy creatures they fly
in wide slow circles a scan tells me
they're able to stay aloft thanks to
internal sacks of buoyant gas
this leads me to wonder if the bulky
rugos floaters can fly using this method
might a true giant be hidden in the
skies
i soon get my answer the largest
airborne creature of darwin 4 reaches
through the clouds this is an ebony
blister wing an animal that is longer
than even the emperor sea striders i
glimpsed earlier in this expedition
although much lighter and more fragile
while i'm only able to glimpse this
creature for a moment i can theorize
that ebony blister wing stays aloft
using the bubble-like bladders on its
wings and body which keep it afloat like
giant balloons and while the diet of
this majestic being is unknown i suspect
it feeds on airborne microscopic
organisms filtering them from the skies
much like a baleen whale filters
zooplankton from the ocean
it is now my final day on darwin 4. just
as i'm returning to my launch site from
the skies descends the most important
life form i've seen
this is an eosapien a highly unusual yet
clearly complex floating organism that
hovers in the air and seems to be
observing me with quiet intelligence i
realize this is my mysterious follower
and it is darwin iv's version of
intelligent life in its hands it holds a
carved defensive weapon not wanting to
alarm the eosapien with any sudden
movements i sit for a while and map out
its anatomy the eu sapiens brain appears
to be housed somewhere in its central
body likely close to its sensory organs
furthermore the eosapien also possesses
flexible digits that enable tool
crafting while right now it seems
eosapiens are only crafting rudimentary
tools perhaps long into the future they
will build a civilization here on darwin
4. for species like the eosapien the
future is full of exciting possibilities
seemingly content with its own
observations the eosapien departs
watching the eosapien leave reminds me
that the time has come for me to also
return home but if you enjoyed this
expedition across darwin 4 as much as i
did i once again encourage you to
purchase the book and check out more of
wayne barlow's incredible work as always
links are in the description also thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this entry
please lend your support to help make
videos like this possible by liking
subscribing and hitting the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things
curious see you in the next video
you